pro kanal ist nicht so der kunde kann
aber ich würde sagen kommt erst jetzt
servus ist hierzu herzlich willkommen
zur video aus dem urlaub und zwar aus
barcelona
wie haben sie den titel schon gesehen
leute heute wird ein video mit meiner
mutter kommen dafür braucht man
selbstverständlich erst als seine mutter
bild bitkom ist ja okay jetzt warte ich
wahrscheinlich wird er von seiner mutter
ein apparat gesicht auf dem kopf ganz
einfach ich wollte einen video endlich
meine mutter zeigen dass sie war auch
gut damit aber da habe ich auch mit max
mit meinem bruder darüber geredet und da
silva alle kommen dass es bald
vielleicht doch nicht so gut finden
unsere mutter zu zeigen weil es so viele
kreisgemeinde menschen enthält gibt
deswegen ist man im heutigen video
nochmal zensiert platz mit der abreise
nach port und titel steht auch dass
meine mutter und meine hinter kommentare
reagiert deswegen zeitlich jetzt die
kommentare und billig geld los an erster
stelle haben wir den kommentar von
melonen gangster der schreibt mädchen
sind coole jungs sind stuhl was wird das
dazu sagen stimmt was macht dann etwas
einseitig die sichtweise der name ist
auch und kompletten geblieben wird oder
rundweg erst an zweiter stelle haben den
kommentar von dem netten zeitgenossen
arm holzmann dem video aus dem august
2016 prüfung hatte die frisur ist gay
ist nicht wieso auch geld aber nicht
ich finde ihn nicht kenne und dann
würden wir uns einfach wochen denkt ja
von haben distanzieren oder antworten
dann haben wir selbstverständlich auch
noch 833 und der kommt mit einem
kommentar essen erklärte weiter viel
spaß scanner und da gab es wie immer
einen absoluten irgendwann auf keinen
fall hängen geblieben oder so der
etabliert hat es sollte mich erst
genannt haben das gab es vorher schon
ein bisschen aber erstmal könnte sich
gesellschaftlich noch mal alles wird
irgendwie mal als geld
das sind informationen aus erster hand
so ist die bestätigung so lehrerin sie
ist muss ich ja sagen dass menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen dann
haben wir nur ist er schreibt wie ich
deine ohren werden hast du also touren
ist das ist mir ja besser besetzt
erklären aber um und ist mit kurzform
für und ich glaube die bürgerlichen
sinne bleibt nicht gerechnet
das ist schon fix streichen kann also
muss man sich ja schon streifen rasch
meisten besticht ich bin ja der vorgang
scheint eine gute nase bis heute diesen
me tender prey kann der kleine schwester
wusste werbung der richtige mensch und
tier mit den netten gentleman hendrix im
rs ähnliches xms der schreibt unter dem
video von mir überhaupt eigentlich nicht
mehr
aber es ist ein sehr großer deutscher
youtuber der gerne mal ein bisschen
seltsame sachen gemacht und ich hab dann
zu einfach zu stellen
ein bisschen lustig gemacht und jetzt
schauen
der streit weiter du denkst auf du bist
der beste kleiner piekser ist gemein hat
ist unklar was die wird entscheiden
[Musik]
gibt's doch nicht nur seine meinung ohne
verletzte ist vor allem richtig krass
weil also ich weiß dass du dich wenn du
jetzt also wirklich glücklich jetzt dass
jetzt die leute sowas schreiben hatte
nicht vorstellen dass so ein kleiner
nager in nantong dass ich dazu gesagt zu
stören immer auch ein bisschen kicken
darunter die gab es fast nicht ins netz
und das werde ich in die öffentlichkeit
sportgruppe sagte mir am anfang wollte
kann ich erzähle was du das ist mir die
ganzen kommentare so ernst genommen der
also zu herzen genommen aber du bist
jetzt ruht hier nur was er zwei söhne
die jetzt schon für youtube machen das
auch bisschen oder wollen definitiv
etwas ist dann kann sich abkoppeln und
letztes ist ja aber das ist jetzt ein
bisschen unter der gürtellinie und
deshalb diesen bereichen schon haben
übertrieben und vor allem die ganze die
also was die garzeit feld ist halt
buchen sondern das sagt man einfach so
zueinander wie halo heutzutage im
internet sagt man einfach nur hallo also
halt nicht so in den sinn
und wenn man jemanden aber so ähnlich
auch preetz weise zu dem thema leute ich
bin selber schuldig das zu sagen und
zwar ich weiß ich bin mein geld aber ist
das manchmal selbst zu marken wie diese
[Musik]
das ist ja wirklich nicht beleidigt will
sind dann so wenn er wieder irgendwas
dummes macht mir wieder den fahrkarten
kontrolliert oder sogar außer sage ich
jetzt eben spaß ziehen so ja das trifft
ja dann wird das wichtigste sagt er aber
nicht sagen
dann hab ich muss nicht richtig
festhalten dabei jetzt kommt wieder ein
kommentar untersucht wie das video ganz
gleich wie von meiner kommentare ich
hab' ich mache wieder abgesagt was über
ihn und dann zum die kommentare von den
ganzen fanboys aber hart und zwar in
diesem fall von cool kanal und der
kommentar heisst war auch mein bruder zu
bereiten der maschinist geiler als
deinen scheiß kanal und hält mich nicht
mein vater ist einer der youtube spieler
der mich tötet der passiert und
abonnieren
liga marschiert also sein vater ist
schon mal einer der youtube spieler
konnte ich von sechs kämpfe statt dann
wird mein vater ist einer bei youtube
spieler spd ler später dann fand das
eine youtube spitz dass ich weiß nicht
was er damit meint aber das ist mal ein
wort das ich glaube er meint ist so dass
sein vater einer der ist dafür gut
gespielt aber mega sinnvoller seine
eigene sondern
erschwerend beleidigt kanal ist nicht so
dem publikum hätte würde ich sagen dass
ich glaube das war's soweit wir sind
gerade im urlaub und das internet oltra
scheiße deswegen wichtig ist mir nicht
so lange machen damit ich heute auch
raus man kann dank dabei dann kanal wäre
verlinke hätten ebenfalls zu verlinken
mir kommt der persönliche vorteile hier
könnte main kanal abonnieren und hier
wird kommt jetzt wieder neuen folge von
was das geht rechts machen und ist vom 1
danach zu schauen
[Musik]